ああああああ
ん
みなさんこんにちは美味しい
再開甲府も食べて素敵なところを聞いて皆さんの気持ちは
ペット素敵なところだなあててエクステ素敵だなんていう気持ちで満たされているん
じゃないかなと思います
私もテッドずシーンはテレビで見ていたんですけれども
まさか自分がこんな
場所に建っているので全然想像がつきませんでした
fedex に出ている方すごい登壇者の方が多くてこれから私自身も素晴らしい話を
するんじゃないかなって思われている方もいらっしゃると思うんですけれども私残念な
ことにまったくすごくありません
まったく
無地とで地域を故障したりもしていませんし塾とにも入っていませんし
映画を撮っていませんし羊も勝っていません
でそんな私がなぜここにいるのかということについてちょっと考えてみたんですけれど
も
これちょっと私の得意なんですけれども名前か分かられる方いらっしゃいますか
実はですね私新しい構造物建造物が勝ったときにこの建物がいかにゾンビに対して耐久
性があるのかということについて考えるのがすごく大好きなんです
で残念ながらこの多いパーク烏山書くのはすごい素敵なところなんですよ
ゾンビに対しての体験せますが低いと言わ
通えないなぁと思いますレコーダーちょっと武器になるかもしれませんがガラスの扉が
あまりにも多すぎるので
親友愚痴が多くて
いきの頃にはありもいけないかなーって思ったりします
までもたんこの話をするために私呼ばれたんじゃないよなということはなくなくわかっ
ています
私このて takes に参加しませんかという話をされたとき15分ぐらいで出会っ
た方
15分ぐらいで私のこと出演決められたんですけどその時に自己紹介で私テイクイット
イージーという団体で
lgbt 性的マイノリティの方々べ釣りやゲイバイセクシュアルトランスジェンダー
の方々のサポート活動をしていますっていう風に話をしたところ
じゃあてといくつでヨーカーっていうことでちょっと拍子に話が旬なんですけど実は
ですね私
セキュリティに関するサポート数の交流会を開いたり
講演会をしたりあるいはが祭を開いたりというような活動はしてるんですけれども
取り立てて何か特別なことをしているとかいうわけではないのでもう活動を続けてても
不安等
後悔でいっぱいの前以上打っています
自分は何もすごくないのにこんな人様に話をするようなことをしていて大丈夫なん
だろうかということだったりあるいは交流会を開いていてひょっとしたら私の不用意な
言動で誰かを傷つけてはいないだろうかということが常に気になって気になって仕方が
なくって何かお役エンタ沿っていう
青函はあまりなくただ公開と不安な毎日を過ごしています
でこんな枚所送っている私がそれでもなぜこのテイクイット22時という団体で活動を
続けているのかというと
書庫のバンドエイドソリューションという言葉を大切にしているからです
ば運営のソリューション初めて機
いったようでからもいらっしゃるかもしれませんがばメイドソリューションというのは
一時しのぎ的な応急処置的な馬名とってか皆さんご存知だと思いますけれども
ケガをしたときにまあとりあえず貼ってその後どうする青急処置として
よそ見をという風なものなんですけれどもどちら低頭
まあ細かいにされてる母一時しのぎがそんなことをしたって何の解決にもならないよと
いう風なイメージで捉えられるかどういいんじゃないかなと思いますが私このバンド
エイドソリューションというのは
いう成績にすごく似た発想じゃないかなというふうに思います
本当は理想としては誰かにいう成績ですよなんて言われなくても困っている人あるいは
席を必要としている方にすっと
譲るような
姿勢というものが皆さん中にそのっていてそれが新搭載していればそのわざわざ優先席
なっても受けなくてもいいはずなんですけれども実際にはそれがなかなか浸透してい
なくて
必要な方に席が行き届かないことがあっということでこのいう成績というものが設け
られていますが
ヴァンガードソリューションというのはまさしく
この優先席と同じように一時しのび的でまぁパッポーキンな解決ではないけれども
きちんと必要な形で必要なものを届けることができる
その維持しの木の間に新しいことを考えることができるというチャンスを生み出して
くれていると思っています
具体的な例を私の活動の中から一つご紹介したいなというふうに思うんですけれども
私今今年に入って4月に一つのニュースを見ました
長崎市内でレズビアンの女性同士のカップルが欠航してをあげましたというニュースを
見ました
このニュースを見たときにすごく私は衝撃を受けます
これまで性的マイノリティに関するいろんな方々とお会いしてきて
でサポート活動とかをしてきたけれども実施
際にパートナーシップを組みたいと家族になりたいんだっていうふうに具体的に希望さ
れている方というのを初めて見たからです
日本報道特集の中ではこのレズビアンカップルの方々が実際に
市の役所に行って実はこういうふうに私たち結婚式を挙げたんですけれども私たち女性
同士だけれどもその二人をパートナーとして認めてくれる何か法律があったりそういう
制度があれば利用したいなって思ってます
っていう風におっしゃられていますその時にし役者の方が大変申し訳ありません
長崎市にはそういったパートナーシップの制度はないので利用することはできません
っていうふうに断られているのを見ます
で攻撃いろんなことを思い出しました
まず最初に思い出したのは私が大学1年生の時に私パッドなぁとしてトランス瞬間恋人
がいいましたその子を巻いた時の戸籍上の性別女性だったんですけれども自分のこと
男性だというふうに思っていて私も男性としてお付き合いをしていたんですけれども
その彼とお付き合
あっているということが彼の親にばれてしまいまして
そのことがきっかけで家を彼が追い出されてしまいました
高校生あ大学1年生なので18才の夏休みに1500円持って遊びに出かけてそのまま
もう二度と帰ってくるなというゲームはを受けていを追い出されてしまったんです
けれどもそれから二人でアパートを探して済んでいいことをしたんですけどすごく彼
ストレスがたまってしまって
その後ストレスが原因で倒れてしまって急遽入院をすることになったんですけれども
この入院をしたときに
私すべての
手続きだったりお金だったり必要な物を揃えたりということを教えたんですけれども
冬の先生から今後ん治療星について話がしたいからということで家族の形を選んで
ください
という風に言われました当時18歳の私でしたので未成年ってすごく大きなメイクには
なったと思いますけど私はいい
19歳の今だったとしても同じような扱いを受けるだろうなと思います
法律として家族でサポートされていないということがこんなにも大きな意思決定の時に
影響を与えるんだということを痛感します
なのでこの時パートナーシップ制度を実際のそんなことがあります
その一方デー
私の家族のことも思い出しましたん
私の家族は幼い頃父の借金が原因で離婚をしたんですけれども
など土はですねその後また新しく借金を重ねていってしまって周囲の人たちもそういう
風になってしまい
サポートもなかなか助けてと言うこともできないまま昨年自殺で亡くなってしまいまし
た
私はそのことをさ
キャッチすることができなくていけとキーパーにもなれずに父が死んでいってしまった
っていうのを
なくなった次の日に知ったんですけれどもすごく衝撃的でした
その方で母は一人になるのが怖いということで再婚をしたんですけれども再婚相手から
言葉によるとスティックバイオレンスを受けていて
でもそれでもずっと将来的に一人ぼっちで死んでいくだがすごく強いということは
原因で彼と別れられなくて今でも結婚生活を続けています
この2つのことを思い出した時に
私にとって結婚制度ってすごく不思議なものだなーって思っています
パートナーシップを組まなければ一人持ち出しして死ぬこともできない
そんな制度を変えていかなければいけないというふうに思っています
ですがその一方でパートナーとして認められたい
安心して好き
人と過ごしていきたいというふうな経理を求めている人たちも実際にいる
2つのカットがありました
この時に珈琲西武やシングルでも安心して暮らしていける制度というもの私が具体的に
想像することがまだできていないので今の現状として実際にできそうなことから始めて
みようというふうに思います
そこでばメイドソリューションとして今制度に疑問を持っているけれども今現在異性間
でしか認められていない権利をまずは行政人を認めてもらおう
その上でさらに今度は進軍人たちにもサポートがあるように心掛けて解決していこうと
いうふうに思ってパートナーシップ生
江戸推進していこうというふうに思いましたん
で実際にいろんな取り組みをして市議の方々をを戻してアプローチをしたり腰作りを
行ったりいろいろ
取り組みをした結果8先月6月にようやく長崎市長がパートナーシップ精度な敵
取り組みますよということで表面のお声をいただきました
そう
ゴク嬉しかったなーって思います
それに対してたくさんの声が寄せられました sa ベースやリアルを通して教えられ
た声の中には
こんな制度がまさか長崎市で導入されるなんて思ってもみなかった
自分が将来好きな人と出会った時にその人と安心して暮らしていけることができる
すごくうれしいっていう風なこれがあったりいやいや私は同じように
そもそも婚姻制度に乗っかるっていうとはみたいな声があったり
て
はたまた year 長崎市がこうやって
市役所としてこんな少子化を推進するような制御を儲けるなんていっていう
まあまあいかにもな犬プレーが回答をいただいたりいろんな声を良さがあります
私にとってバブ8ソリートが一番のセッターというのはこの超えたというふうに思って
います
羽根のソリューション行動した時に応急処置的な行動であったとしても行動を起こせば
何か者の反応が返ってきます
何かしらの反応が返ってきたのに対して改良して
いくことによって世界はより良くなっていくというふうに私は信じています
これがずなんですけれども行動を起こしました
実際にはもっと高い理想がありますけれどもできることを始めようということで
複雑な気持ちの中でもパープレーとソリューションとして同性パトの宿条例の推進を
進めていった結果
市長が表明をしてくれてその頬によって周囲からいろんなコメントが返ってきたので
それを踏まえた制度づくりはこれから行っていくというふうななんかになります
まあ穴は何が言いたいのかといいますと
どんなに素晴らしいアイディアも頭の中にあるだけではないものと同じだというふうに
思います
例えばどんなに拙い発想であったとしてもどんなにくだらない発想であったとしても何
も素晴らしいことを考えて行動に移さない人よりも
た凧パーセントのアイディアでもチャレンジしてみた人もそのチャレンジにこそ意味が
ある
意義があるという風に考えています
band aid ソリューションという言葉を聞いたときに自分は何もできないただ
の凡人店っていうふうに思ってる人もいるんじゃないかなと思いますあのアイデアも
ないよって思っている方もいるんじゃないかなと思います
私も同じように何のアイディアもなく何の取り柄もなくゾンビのことを考えるくらい
しか取り柄がないんですけれども
それでも何かした行動起こせば少しずつ前に進んでいきます
理想に歩ずつ近づいていきます誰も置き去りにしない社会に受けて私の父も母もか
私自身もパートナーも太皆さん自身も誰も置いていかれの明日のために今もしできる
ことがあるなら
を
恐れずにチャレンジで市チャレンジを敷いてみてほしいなっていうふうに思います以上
で私の話は終了ですねそのご静聴ありがとうございました
ran
[拍手]